sonha ficar desistir tefé fosse fácil
não é nem vai ser bom
a notícia boa tarde boa noite bom dia
mas eu quero falar para vocês que o meu
nome de túlio felipe são baita de um
sonhador como vocês e eu tenho 11 anos e
eu tive para exercer e brown
boa tarde boa noite o bomdia.lu quero
falar que é uma grande honra participar
até de ex policial nos 2015 quero falar
pra vocês que agradeço a todo mundo que
está presente é bastante gente quer
falar pra vocês também um pouco da minha
história eu tive deficiência tive também
isso não tem como não ser apagado eu
quero falar pra vocês que desde o dia
que eu tive deficiência eu sou um
sonhador porque meu primeiro sonho foi
caminhar meu segundo foi jogar futebol
conseguir um terceiro foi participar da
promoção de entrar com os jogadores na
copa do mundo eo meu quarto foi
participada bota do mundo 10 meio
flamengo graças ao amigo daniel mate
quero falar também pra vocês que também
depois disso eu pensei assim
caramba eu já entrei com noel um melhor
goleiro do mundo pra mim que não sabe
ainda né então avançar
ué mas fazer o quê não sou vidente quero
falar pra vocês então que aí eu pensei
ah vou introduzir na alemanha não tem
muito recurso mas eu vou pegar em alguém
vai ter que me ajudar
quero falar daí também que se alguém que
me ajudou a ortopé ortopé uma pessoa
muito legal
então não é uma pessoa simplesmente mais
um grupo de pessoas e também depois
disso pensei ah tem mais uma bota do
mundo vou participar através então eu me
senti um jogador também assim gente eu
sou um sonhador e quero falar pra vocês
que não desistam
o sonho de vocês agora meu próximo sua
intromissão neymar e eu quero falar
também pra vocês que vocês não podem
disse desistir dos sonhos a porque gente
porque assim vocês após o que sempre
sonho e não é bom sonhar
eu sonho sempre por isso que eu cantei
essa música e falava também pra vocês
que mundo nosso não passa de um sonho um
sonho que se tornou realidade
e também eu falo pra vocês mais uma vez
que eu espero que vocês realizem o sonho
de vocês como atrás porque vocês vão
conseguir se não conseguir valeu a força
de vontade aí getúlio que beleza cará e
aí o barbudo tudo bem tudo bem
beleza é muito bom tê ouvir mas aí e me
convidaram pra gente fazer umas
perguntas também a pua prade santa louca
top é legal cara mas eu tô sabendo que
além de tudo isso de correr atrás dos
seus sonhos e de ajudar os outros a
fazerem a realizarem os seus sonhos
também tem uma rádio agora me conta essa
história
bom a minha rádio é todos os sábados às
10 horas eu converso muito é uma
conversa para ela não tem direção então
é sempre o é mas fazer o quê é hoje mais
petição de dançam após também é legal
já participei com daniel matic é o
evento da batata do mundo
participei com quem mas a mas sei que
foi o objetivo básico é portanto já
invadiu programa aí a produção não
deixou e mas fazer o quê
mas o que faz a rota rádio entre os
famosos varge a entrevistei o popó bueno
cacá bueno o bing barrichello
um monte de gente é é não entrevistou
anjos também se diz é um papai noel na
entrevista ele é comum ver futebol de
entrevista me faz uma pergunta é bom bom
dia 20 sites web centra no ar hoje pela
várias vezes
getúlio companhia todos os sábados é uma
grande honra participar e agora eu tô
com o marco do papai noel da atlântida
porã
bom é uma grande honra receber todo teu
nome
obrigado meu nome é verdade o meu nome e
ganho bernardes
bom vocês agora não precisa mais dele
mas de fora mas por é mais mas é bem
mais fácil eu quero falar para vocês
também não é verdade não quero falar com
você eu quero perguntar pra esse barbudo
aqui quando começou na internet
eu comecei na atlântida fácil vai fazer
dez anos agora e no pretinho nove anos e
conecta lentas e que não faria de novo
assim
a farra com a sunga é o papai noel é
verdade sabe que a gente lembra que eu
fui no centro de sombra neto viu aquele
vídeo lei que eu perca alguma coisa mas
eu não tomasse fazendo aquelas coisas de
tudo para ela tá bom é idade né
mas agora é isso aí é isso aí o cara vai
ficar mesmo assim ele tem que lindo
gleisi acaba jogando a mesma bola que
ele é com uma barriguinha aí é um pouco
é o que diz uma coisa que tu faz pra
ajudar as outras crianças a realizarem o
sonho dela isso aí bom eu escutei falar
pra vocês que é tanta coisa na minha
vida em resumo os pequenos que que assim
eu jô sua criança simbolizando do
teleton representa as crianças no
instituto imaginem pré grande são paulo
e olha que eu tive a idéia e resolvi
juntasses o instituto de aceder com o
teleton eu pensei assim após que as
crianças do instituto nunca pegaram e
foram por um teleton então selecionei
duas crianças mais três pessoas para
acompanhá los inclusive útil do neymar
júnior e pansy ho leva elas realizar o
sonho e sabe qual é o meu próximo sonho
agora apesar de seu neymar claro né
com a oportunidade que eu tenho quero
saber quando é que vocês vão falar da
alemanha não ser negociar um louco
assim eu pensei agora já que eu realizei
o sonho das crianças
pensei agora em fazer diferente às
crianças da aacd e visitar o estudo
neymar e quero falar pra vocês que o
neymar um estudo neymar agora vai ter de
aniversário dia 13 de novembro
e eu vou estar lá é óbvio né e
oportunidade única como na vida de vocês
vocês acham que o tedh axn vai ter o
mesmo que hoje eu falando após
eficiência a produção me convidar mas
não vai ter um momento tão em voga como
antes era tarde demais e túlio são
trovador embora nem vai trovador é só o
trovador nós temos aqui ó é marqueteiro
ali dance e jazz in tha então assim já
falou do instituto neymar
tudo já foi visitado na alemanha tudo tu
participou de um evento muito legal que
falou rapidamente aqui que é o bota do
mundo
qual foi a importância do bota do mundo
para realizar alterações ao poeta
esperto entende esse barbudo a barba
está ajudando é bom
o bota do mundo meu amigo daniel matias
e um pessoal todo um abraço pra ele e
minha amiga bola' essa ideia em novo
hamburgo o primeiro depois na arena do
grêmio em pleno de tudo neymar
por isso que eu conheci instituto em
março a criança
um abraço sempre câmera man bom
a então eu peguei pensei puxa o evento
legal porque como tinha falta de uma
criança eu vou participar fazer o que
jogar uma bolinha da enganada
então eu participei e fica em terceiro
lugar
eu fiquei com o uruguai junto com gavião
meu amigo gremista e infelizmente mais
respeito
então fui lá conversei com ele ficamos
em terceiro lugar pelo caso ismael
flamengo esqueceu troféu também sabe tom
sentimental mas bem
aí depois eu participei acho que dessa
vez eu fui goleiro da bota do mundo em
2014 ano passado na arena do grêmio em
sap treinou com noir o goleiro um tapete
que ela graminha básica lá queria estar
no lugar do gás é bom mas não é isso que
interessa saber que estavam lá o papai
noel piers e eu conheci ele mais uma vez
que encontrei ele
ele agora esse ano o instituto neymar
julho
acho que é a melhor bola do mundo que eu
já fiz foi o instituto muito obrigado eo
bota do monte
quero falar também pra vocês que eu
nunca desisti tem mais o incêndio além
do neymar
além de tudo e cada vez que abre portas
né que o marqueteiro me ajuda me a
fotógrafa que o nome do martelo a deles
é grave e ele fica me trollando e chama
ele de getúlio felipe ele como inveja é
então um abraço pra minha amiga e uma no
coelho e eu quero falar pra vocês que eu
cada vez que eu falo para vocês eu me
sinto muito feliz porque após que vocês
tiveram um tempo que ele é um vago pra
participar e que então muito obrigado
mas não vou terminar vou aproveitar né
porque eu não sei se o governo em ano
que vem mas eu vou cobrar vão encher o
saco da produção que eu quero ouvir o
blá muito bom getúlio olha só na
pergunta é o que eu quero saber antes da
próxima é me convidaram pra lá na terra
a jovem é e papai noel e anjos e mas
assim eu quero falar isto tem esse
projeto dos sonhos e ajudando a
criançada realizar os seus sonhos também
na qual que atua como entende a
importância do sonho na vida das pessoas
tanto chegou lá do contou que tem
história do primeiro sonho era caminhar
nfa e aí depois de conseguir realizar
esse sonho começou a buscar outros
sonhos sim né
qual é a importância na vida da gente de
sonhar
chen é sempre bom né
marcelo eu acho que vocês sempre tiveram
grande sonho
vamos poder conhecer um jogador de
futebol que o banco francês tem esse
sonho então falo pra você tem que
batalhar corre atrás sua camisa
porque depois vai ter uma valorização
então é sempre pensei nisso então
agradeço todos os dias que eu tenho uma
boa saúde apesar de tomar deficiência
não muito bom mas me sinto uma pessoa
normal porque já me adaptei e falo para
vocês também que vocês não podem existir
o deus dos sonhos
eu quero saber aqui qual pessoa aí
queria realizar um sonho há alguém quer
falar aí pode ontem problema que alguém
que levantavam falar com uma galera
quero entender eu quero que vocês falem
também ocupando esse tempo só tenho dois
minutos vamos lá 80 que a seleção vamos
lá gente alguém quer falar mas só tem
uma hashtag que tá usando aí é pra
galera conheceu o projeto de sons como é
que é
olhe que ligam site tega pensei em todos
vocês league cresce um marqueteiro que
me ajudou a bola' que é hashtag sempre
quero falar pra vocês que eu fico muito
honrado em participar até de ex 2015
espera depois eu quero saber da resposta
quem tem um sonho queria realizar o e
gente eu quero saber falta pouquinho por
favor me ajudem quem seu nome
geovanna qual seu sonho nets 10
bom eu sou em s
se eu fosse tudo eu correria atrás
corria atrás de uma pessoa que pudesse
ajudar também a ideia que eu tive agora
vou pegar em bola com todo o bairro tem
uma arrecadação para te ajudar e quando
em convidados todo mundo do bairro para
fazer uma aula experimental eu quero
falar pra vocês que agradeço eu agradeço
a você a gente espera que tenha uma boa
profissão de dançarina quero ver depois
de dança bem
agradeço a todo mundo muito obrigado
obrigado barbudão douglas getúlio eu que
agradeço a gente agradece a presença
numerosa e quando é que agora um
pretinho objeto não você só come quieto
foi no pretinho algumas vezes a itu
tomou conta do programa não deixou
ninguém falar cara a sensei bom está
convidado para ir de novo tá bom diz que
fui eu que te convidei tá tá bom tá aí
ela tem pra galera já promete a colisão
tudo bem tá agradeço a vocês muito
obrigado foi uma grande honra quem se
ama aqui
otegi ex 2015 abraça todo mundo que me
ajudou a realizar um sonho fala pra
vocês que sonhos eu nunca desisto
hashtag sonha sempre muito obrigado
fui ao gent